and meanwhile earlier tonight two
Democratic Congress women also deeply
impacted by their derangement syndrome
just could not bring themselves to sit
and listen to the President's speech yes
both Alexandria Acacio Cortez the real
Speaker of the House and congresswoman
Presley boycotted the State of the Union
they were missed sorely naturally of
Cascio Cortez spent the night sulking on
Instagram and meanwhile Senator Lindsey
cram tweeted quote I can't blame ALC for
boycott in the State of the Union must
be painful for a committed socialist to
hear the record of accomplishments
regarding economic growth and prosperity
we have achieved under President Trump
we will scroll them again as we speak
joining us now with reaction South
Carolina Senator Lindsey Graham you know
you're tweeting today actually retweeted
you because you are on it you're on a
roll today you had your talk show game
on just like when you said be s on the
show twice I was very proud of you which
I can do what I have to deal with you
know six weeks of getting beat up but
here's my we are watching something
historic unfold and that's our country
succeeding that's what America and then
the other side yes a compelling
narrative that every American from every
bet walk walk of life is doing better
economically our military's strong since
Reagan I've never seen it this strong
terrorists are dead that deserved to be
dead and when that soldier came to see
his wife and his two kids I just I just
lost it so President Trump is well on
his way to getting reelected and aoc
probably is glad she didn't come because
if you're a committed socialist this
speech was a speech from hell because it
talked about freedom the power of the
individual versus the power of
government we talked about prosperity
for all best achieved through economic
growth lower taxes less regulation this
is a speech of socialists could not
stand in two speaker Pelosi you can tear
up the speech but you can't tear up the
accomplishments and that's what this
race is gonna be about in 2020 that's a
powerful line you know as I as I look
through all of this and you were
you had a career moment rightly so in
the Cavanaugh case we know how hard you
work to get the truth out and the double
standard and breathtaking hypocrisy
there's a lot of winning going on that
will scroll that again now if we can put
that up the success of the president and
but there's also a lot of losers winners
and losers I would say here and I would
venture you had a pretty good guess of
that yeah well we're going to acquit the
president tomorrow in a bipartisan
fashion this has been a sham of an
impeachment but I think the American
people are going to win when we equip
because they can vote for this good men
again who in their right mind would fire
Donald Trump after his accomplishments
in his first term but we did lose months
of time to do things on behalf of the
American people through impeachment and
the process in the house the biggest
winner is Mitch McConnell you kicked
Schumer's but yet again he didn't
Cavanaugh and now he's done it in
impeachment but the biggest winner of
all by far is President Trump because he
comes out of this thing stronger he's
got more support today than he did
before impeachment and he's well on his
way I think to getting a second term and
Pelosi is a major loser she's lost the
speakership to AOC to leave in the squad
and let me tell you ship is actually a
winner because he's going to be the heir
apparent to Dianne Feinstein and yet
tells you how screwed up California
politics is you know Nancy boys she says
I tore it up I was trying to find one
page with truth on it and I couldn't it
is so petty
they couldn't stick to that challenge
the supership they couldn't stand for a
young woman getting a scholarship or
with any but job creation yeah I want to
make a challenge to Nancy Pelosi give me
facts to dispute what the president said
about economic growth among all sectors
of society for women for
african-americans for Hispanics for low
income earner
don't tear up the speech tell me where
it's wrong and you know why Trump's
gonna win the speech is absolutely the
truth and the best is yet to come
senator if you get me that torn up
speech I'll donate 25 grand a favorite
charity and I'm gonna I have which would
be my campaign okay exactly okay Senator
Lindsey Graham South Carolina thank you
for being with us tonight